hey 42 here the designer of Saddam
Hussein's bunker was the grandson of the
woman who built Adolf Hitler's bunker
welcome to RIF the human brain takes an
11 million bits of information every
second but it's only aware of 40 of them
98 percent of British homes have
carpeted floors but in Italy only 2% do
all of the words written on Twitter
every day would fill a 10 million page
book a burning candle creates 1.5
million tiny diamonds per second people
earning over 14 thousand pounds a year
are amongst the richest 4% on the planet
the ancient Greeks had no word for
religion Italy's biggest business is the
Mafia it turns over a hundred and
seventy eight billion dollars a year and
account for seven percent of the
country's GDP kangaroos koalas wombats
and Tasmanian Devils all have free
vaginas in the 17th century the salary
of the governor of Barbados was paid in
sugar worldwide sales of cocaine and
more than Microsoft McDonald's and
Kellogg's combined thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42